I woke up in the middle of the night
with chills and vomiting and what I now
recognized was shortness of breath I
couldn't walk and I couldn't speak more
than maybe you know two to three words
and eventually I couldn't eat either
eating just made me feel like I couldn't
get enough air my name is Fiona
Lowenstein I'm based in New York City
and I'm a writer producer yoga teacher
and I run body politic which is a queer
feminist wellness collective and I'm 26
I have no pre-existing conditions no
autoimmune disorders no respiratory
issues I work out six times a week I'm a
yoga teacher again I work in wellness so
in many ways I kind of think of myself
as you know the picture of health so I
definitely didn't think of myself as a
part of one of these you know vulnerable
populations
I first became sick on Friday March 13th
I felt fine all day and then around 8:00
or 9:00 p.m. started getting a headache
and just feeling feverish the next
morning Saturday I had a cough and then
some day actually the fever went away
and I seem to be doing a lot better I
thought that that was kind of it and I
would just you know be maybe we're
covering a little bit on Monday but
started making plans it's like shower
and just get back to some of the
household things that I had neglected
and then Sunday night into Monday
morning I woke up in the middle of the
night with chills and vomiting and what
I now recognized was shortness of breath
even though again I was isolating from
the moment I got sick and thinking this
could be coronavirus I really just
didn't believe that it could get that
serious I just didn't want to first of
all take away resources from other
people that might need them more I
didn't want to leave my house if I had
coronavirus because I didn't want to
risk infecting others and I didn't live
within walking distance at the hospital
so I was gonna have to take a park
service there like uber or lyft and then
also there was a part of me that was
like what if I don't have the virus and
then I go to the hospital and I got put
in a coronavirus award and I catch the
virus
so I mean I'm very very grateful to my
partner my doctor for essentially just
forcing me to go because I do think that
I wanted the last possible moment the
walk from the lift door to the emergency
room like front desk was I couldn't even
do it in one shot I had to sit down
halfway through in the middle of the
street and catch my breath we called
ahead of going to the hospital which as
I understand is what anyone should do we
went through security and then we went
to the front desk and I immediately had
to sit down and they just told me to go
sit in the regular waiting room then
suddenly I hear the receptionist like
screaming at security because apparently
they were supposed to have given us
medical masks when they found out that
we were there for coronavirus and they
didn't so we were given masks and then
we were ushered into a separate waiting
room that was much smaller much more
crowded the original waiting when we
were in which was almost empty I think
that was just kind of the general
admission room and then we were put in
the coronavirus room and there was only
one seat left in there you were only
there for a couple minutes though before
they put us in our own in our own room
and this was me and my partner who had
been taking care of me but trying to
isolate for me as much as possible we
waited I would say about four hours
before we saw dr. which you know the ER
can be like that in at this point it was
like 11 p.m. at night sometimes that can
happen but I think also they were a bit
overwhelmed no one there was at all
surprised to see me like they were
constantly telling me that there were
lots of other young people who were
being admitted and they were
increasingly seeing more and more people
in their 20s and 30s the main thing they
gave me was oxygen but even that it took
I would say six hours from us first
getting there for me to get the oxygen
mask the doctors and the nurses were
incredibly frustrated I mean they told
me that the protocols were constantly
changing for them they told me when I
got there that this hospital didn't
provide tests then they told me that it
did but the test results want to be back
for ten days then they told me that it
had changed and I can get my test
results in a few hours then they told me
that I wouldn't be able to get them for
24 hours I mean there they were very
confused and they were very open about
the fact that they were not getting
clear instructions
I was also told by the person who did my
EKGs said you know we're not getting
tested either and I know I've been
exposed at least three times and we
don't have the protective gear that we
need and then another nurse said to me
I'm really worried that you know in a
couple weeks time we could be having to
make decisions about who lives and who
dies it's just a really weird experience
to go to the hospital and be a patient
and you know you're used to kind of the
doctors and the nurses knowing what's
going on and taking care of you and I
almost felt like we were taking care of
each other like they were also in you
know a state of distress and dealing
with arguably more than I was and it was
it was a very hectic situation and I'm
very grateful to them all because they
were usually emotionally supportive at
points when I was here breaking down
just from being alone and being stared
and they were working constantly both of
us were told in the ER that we were not
eligible for testing we were told that
we had to have had contact with someone
who knew they were Kovach positive had
tested positive or we had to have
traveled to Japan Italy China or Korea
I'm sure these rules have changed
slightly since then that was very
difficult because like I had had contact
with someone who was having all the same
symptoms as me and had started those
symptoms a few days prior to mine and
I'm pretty sure that's where I got it
from but she couldn't get tested either
for the same reasons so I have no idea
why I eventually got tested it was the
whole experience of being tested was
very odd they came in they swab at my
nose in the morning without saying
anything to me they didn't tell me I was
getting a coronavirus test and it was
almost there was like a secret some sort
of secrecy around it and then I got
admitted and they told me that the ER
had actually lost all the tests that
they had done that night so they had to
Reese wob me and the test is not it's
not pleasant it's like a q-tip very far
up your nose basically type of sensation
so then I got tested again
when I got to the hospital I asked if I
should notify all of the students that
were in my yoga classes for the past two
weeks and honestly the response I got
was very disheartening everyone kind of
said honestly it doesn't really matter
because at this point people could have
been exposed through so many different
sources the level of you know community
contagion is so high that they could get
it just from riding the subway or just
from walking down the street and bumping
into someone or go into the grocery
store and touching something some
someone else has touched but they felt
by that point they were like sure it
doesn't hurt to tell them but it's
really impossible at this stage to trace
back points of contagion the studio did
contact all the students that I was in
class with in the past two weeks but
that was not something that the doctor
seemed to think was necessarily gonna
save a lot of people
I got discharge instructions from the
hospital that said that the Department
of Health would call me in three to five
days about being retested to see if I
test negative I never received a call
from the Department of Health the
instructions also said to wait seven
days from the positive Cova test and if
those last three of the seven days are
fever free without Tylenol that then I
am eligible to go to a testing center
and get tested this all seemed just very
unlikely to me because it was so hard to
get a test in the first place so it said
if I didn't hear from the voh I should
call them myself the number they gave me
at the hospital was an incorrect number
to someone's personal voicemail so yeah
I mean
[Music]
the myth of invulnerability is just that
it is a myth we absolutely can contract
this virus and we absolutely can become
symptomatic and we can become
hospitalized we're a generation that
tends to live with roommates were a
generation that sometimes lives with our
parents right we a lot of us known of
health insurance a lot of us don't of
job security so there's a lot of ways in
which we're vulnerable to this kind of
in specific ways and also ways in which
we can easily pass it to each other to
you know more vulnerable family members
so it's especially important we're also
a you know a very large portion of the
population Millennials and Gen Z so we
can have a pretty big impact with the
decisions that we make here all of us
have made poor decisions during this
crisis at some point right the
government certainly made poor decisions
which is why we're in this situation
where the burden of social
responsibility is being placed on
individuals to the extent that it is but
also each one of us had a point in the
past you know two or three months where
we didn't take this as seriously as we
should have maybe it was before the
information got to our country or you
know before or I tested positive for
coronavirus right I don't want people to
feel you know so embarrassed or so
ashamed of those past decisions that
they ultimately double down on them and
don't course-correct I think I've gotten
a lot of messages from people since I
started sharing my story people our age
are saying like I want to be brutally
honest I really was not taking this as
seriously as I needed to I was still
visiting friends at their apartments I
was sharing food and I now understand
the seriousness of it and I'm going to
change what I'm doing so I think that's
the most important thing is like you
know don't let the shame at what you
might have done in the past few weeks or
the actions you might have failed to
take don't let that stop you from kind
of disrupting whatever social dynamic
you're in if those people aren't doing
what they need to be doing you actually
have the opportunity here to sincerely
impact the course of this public health
crisis so in that sense it can feel
empowering actually I think
and I'm gonna try and continue to do
work in the coming weeks especially to
provide you know emotional support and
resources for people who are dealing
with these symptoms because I know how
scary it can be to be alone and you know
maybe far from family and be exhibiting
these symptoms that you've been seeing
on the news for so long we all have to
change as a result of this like there is
no going back to the way that the world
was before but as many people have
pointed out we shouldn't want to go back
right because that's the broken
healthcare structure and you know the
government that got us into this
situation to begin with so my hope is
that you know the world will change
permanently after this but that it will
be for the better
[Music]